نقلت وكاله تسنيم عن قائد البحريه في
الحرس الثوري الايراني قوله انه تم انشاء
وحده تضم بحار متطوعين لتنفيذ عمليات في
الخليج بسفنهم المسلحه بالصواريخ واضاف ان
قوات التعبئه في البحريه تضم 55 الفا من
المتطوعين اضافه الى 33 الف
مركب معنا من واشنطن السيد و المسؤول
السابق في الخارجيه الامريكيه اهلا بك
معنا سيد ويام لماذا لم تلجا الولايات
المتحده الى سيناريوهات اكثر
دبلوماسيه قبل ان تقوم بتشكيل هذه القوه
المتعدده
الجنسيات لست متاكدا من ماهيه هذه
خطوات الدبلوماسيه مع الحوثيين اذا ليس
هناك مفاوضات ما بين الحوثيين والامريكيين
لكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لديها
مشاورات مع السعوديه والبحرين ودول اخرى
حوالي تسع دول بعد هذه الهجمات التي طالت
مجموعه من الدول او مجموعه من السفن
التابعه لدول مختلفه في البحر الاحمر في
الاونه الاخيره واعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في الاه الاخيره اسقطت
مجموعه من المسيرات التي اطلقها الحوثين
السؤال المطروح الان هل ستكون هناك ردود
افعال قويه من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من خلال استهداف هذه المسيرات
من م صادرها واتمنى ان لا تتطور الامور
وتتسع رقعه الحرب راينا تلك الهجمات
التي كانت في سوريا وفي العراق اذا كان
هناك عديد من الهجمات في الاونه الاخيره
وفي تثور الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حاولت ان ترد بشكل دقيق سيد ويليام انت
ذكرت انك لست متاكد من ان كان هناك خيارات
دبلوماسيه ولكن جماعه انصار الله
الحوثييين تحدثوا عن مطالب واضحه ل من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي ادخال
المساعدات الى قطاع غزه وفك الحصار عنه
ووقف هذه الحرب الم يكن هناك فرصه امام
الولايات المتحده للتجاوب مع هذه المطالب
قبل اتخاذ هكذا خطوه في البحر
الاحمر نعم ينبغي الاستجابه لهذه المطالب
لكن ليس
ب مطالبه من الحوثيين ينبغي ان يكون هناك
امداد للمزيد من الفلسطينين بالغداء لكن
ليس لان ذلك ياتي من الحوثين اعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تركز بشكل
كبير الان على البعد الانساني وعلى ادخال
المساعدات لم يكن ذلك بسبب ضغط من الحوثين
نعتقد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تفكر
بهذا الوع بشكل جيد والحوثيون لا يؤثرون
بالخيارات ولا بالسياسات الامريكيه في هذا
الخصوص على كل حال لم تبقى اي جهه انسانيه
ودوليه الا وطالبت بادخال المساعدات باقل
تقدير دعني اسالك سيد لورنس عن المهام
الموكله للدول المشاركه في هذه القوه هل
ستكون كل الدول على نفس المسار نفس
الاستراتيجيه في كيفيه التعامل مع الظروف
الطارئه في البحر الاحمر حال بدء
عملها
هذا هو الشيء الاهم لا نتوفر على بيانات
ولا معلومات بخصوص هذا الموضوع هل ستتحرك
هذه الدول فقط عندما يكون هناك هجوم من
قبل الحوثييين نحن لا ندري ولا نتوفر على
معلومات كافيه بخصوص طريقه عمل هذه
القوه طبعا سيكون من المثير للاهتمام ان
ما هي الدول التي قد تنضم اللائحه الصين
او اليابان او الدول الاخرى هناك مجموعه
من الدول المعنيه نحن نعلم بان هولندا
وبان دول اخرى موجوده ضمن هذه القوه لكن
هذه السفن التي تعبر البحر الاحمر هي من
العديد من دول العالم سنرى ما هي الدول
التي او ستنضم لهذه القوه في قادم الايام
نحن نعرف ان هناك وضع هش في
المنطقه شكرا جزيلا لك من السيد ويام
لورنس المسؤول السابق في الخارجيه
الامريكيه